the Senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will please
lead us in prayer
let us pray Almighty God as we resume
this impeachment trial let your will be
done enlighten our senators as you show
them your will Lord guide them with your
wisdom supporting them with your power
in spite of disagreements may they
strive for civility and respect may they
respect the right of the opposing side
to differ regarding convictions and
conclusions give them the wisdom to
distinguish between facts and opinions
without lambasted the messengers we pray
in your strong name amen
in reciting the pledge allegiance to the
flag
as one nation under God indivisible with
liberty the Centers please be seated
if there is no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date hearing no objection so ordered the
sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation there you hear you hear you
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the Senate
of the United States is sitting in the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States
justice the majority leader is
recognized or all of our colleagues some
information about scheduling today will
plan to take short breaks every two to
three hours and will accommodate a
30-minute recess for dinner assuming it
is needed until the house managers have
finished their opening presentation with
scheduling purposes we've organized
tomorrow's session to convene at 10 a.m.
and run for several hours as the
President's Council begins their
presentation pursuant to the provisions
of Senate resolution 483 the managers
for the House of Representatives have 7
hours and 53 minutes remaining to make
the presentation of their case the
Senate will now hear you mr. chief
this Senators distinguished council of
the president I keep wanting to say good
morning but good afternoon I just wanted
to give a very brief orientation to the
argument you'll hear today we will begin
with Jason crow who was talking about
the conditionality of the military
assistance this is the latter part
although not the end of the
argumentation on the application of the
Constitution and law as it respects
article 1 the abuse of power
I'll have a presentation after mr. crow
and soon thereafter we will conclude the
presentation on article 1 will then
begin the presentation on article to
once again applying the Constitution and
law to the facts on the president's
obstruction of Congress we will then
have some concluding thoughts and then
turn it over to the president's counsel
and that is what you should expect for
the day and with that I will now yield
to mr. crow of Colorado good after
I woke up this morning and walked to my
local coffee shop where unlike my
esteemed colleague mr. Jeffries from New
York nobody complained to me about
Colorado baseball so I could only
conclude that this is only a New York
Yankees problem as mr. Schiff mentioned
we talked last night about the July 25th
call and the multiple officials who had
confirmed the intent of the president
and withholding the aid so now I'd like
to turn to what happened around the time
that the aid was lifted and we know that
the aid was lifted ultimately on
September 11th but it wasn't lifted for
any legitimate reason it was only lifted
because President Trump had gotten
caught now let's go through how we know
that on August 26th the whistleblower
complaint had been sent to the Director
of National Intelligence and public
reports indicate that President Trump
was told about the complaint by White
House Counsel Pat's abalone on some
tipper fifth though the scheme became
public an editorial in the Washington
Post on that day for the first time
publicly explicitly linked the military
aid hold and the investigations that
President Trump wanted now keep in mind
that public scrutiny of the president's
hold increased exponentially after this
became public and this is where things
start moving really fast a few days
later on September 9th the House
investigative committees publicly
announced their investigation of
president's conduct in Ukraine
Lieutenant Colonel vid Minh testified to
the National Security Council and others
at the White House learned about the
investigation when it was announced and
a colleague of his said that it might
have the effect of releasing 2:8 and on
that same day the House Intelligence
Committee learns that the administration
had withheld the whistleblower complaint
from Congress the scheme was unraveling
and what happens two days later
Trump released the military aid he only
released it after he got caught but
there's another reason we know the
president lifted the aide only because
he got caught because there's no other
explanation the testimony of all of the
witnesses confirms it
both lieutenant-colonel vid Minh and
Miss Williams testified that they were
not provided any reason for lifting the
hold then men testified that nothing on
the ground had changed in the two months
of the hold and mark sandy of the OMB
could also confirm that an ambassador
Taylor too testified that quote I was
not told the reason why the hold had
been lifted now let me take a moment to
address another defense I expect you
will hear that the aide was released in
the investigations were never announced
so therefore no harm no foul
right well this defense would be
laughable if this issue wasn't so
serious
first I've spoken over the past three
days about the real consequences of
inserting politics into matters of war
real people real lives are at stake
every day every hour matters so no the
delay wasn't meaningless just ask the
Ukrainians sitting in trenches right now
and to this day they are still waiting
on 18 million dollars of the aid that
hasn't reached them Jennifer Williams
who attended the Warsaw meeting with
Vice President Prince described
President zelinsky's focus during this
time and you testified in your
deposition that in that conversation
President Solinsky emphasized that these
military assistance the Security
Assistance was not just important to
assist Ukraine in fighting a war against
Russia but that it was also symbolic in
nature and what did you what did you
understand him to mean by that
president Solinsky explained that more
than just equally with the financial and
physical value of the assist
that it was the symbolic nature of that
assistance that really was the show of
us support for Ukraine and for Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and I think he was you he was stressing
that to the vice president to really
underscore the need for the security
assistance to be released and that if
the United States was holding the
Security Assistance is it also true then
that Russia could see that as a sign of
weakening us support for Ukraine and
take advantage of that I believe that's
what the president president Solinsky
was was indicating that any signal or
sign that US support was wavering would
be construed by Russia as potentially an
opportunity for them to strengthen their
own hand in Ukraine this is an important
point particularly when the president
and his attorneys tried to argue no harm
no foul the financial assistance itself
was really important to Ukraine no
question about it but the aid was
equally important as a signal to Russia
of our support for Ukraine and
regardless of whether the aid was
ultimately released the fact that the
hold became public sent a very clear
signal to Russia that our support for
Ukraine was wavering in Russia was
watching very closely for any sign of
weakness the damage was done now any
possible doubt about whether the aid was
linked to the investigations has been
erased by the president's own chief of
staff and we've seen this video before
during the trial but there's a really
good reason for this it's a complete
admission on national TV that the
military aid was conditioned on Ukraine
helping the president's political
campaign here once again is what
Mulvaney said that he also mentioned to
me and past the the the the corruption
related to the DNC server absolutely no
question about that but that's it and
that's why we held up the money and when
pressed that he had just confessed to
the very quid pro quo that President
Trump had been denying Mulvaney doubled
down you just described is a quid pro
quo it is funding will not flow
unless the investigation into the into
the Democratic server happened as well
we do we do that all the time with
foreign policy if you read the news
reports and you believe them what a
McKinney's say yesterday
well McKinney said yesterday that he was
really upset with the political
influence in foreign policy that was one
of the reasons he was so upset about
this
and I have news for everybody get over
it there's going to be political
influence and foreign policy I'm talking
now remember at the time he made these
statements bovania was both the head of
OMB and the acting chief of staff at the
White House he knew about all of the
legal concerns he also knew about the
president's so-called drug deal as
ambassador Bolton called it he knew
exactly what was going on in the Oval
Office and how OMB implemented the
president's illegal order to hold the
eight Mulvaney confirmed why the
president ordered the hold it was not to
develop further policy to counter
Russian aggression it was not to
convince the Ukrainians to implement
additional anti-corruption reforms and
it was not to pressure our allies to
give more to Ukraine now since we won't
have an opportunity to respond to the
president's presentation I want to take
a minute to respond to some of the
arguments that I expect them to make you
will notice I'm sure that they will
ignore significant portions of the
evidence while trying the cherry-pick
individual statements here and there to
manufacture defenses but don't be fooled
one defense you may hear is that the aid
was held up to allow for a policy review
this is what the administration told the
GAO at one point but the evidence shows
the opposite the evidence shows that the
administration didn't conduct a review
at any time after the president ordered
the whole Laura Cooper was not aware of
any review of the funding conducted by
DOD in July August or September
and similarly George Kent testified that
the State Department did not conduct and
was never asked to conduct a review of
funding administrative by the State
Department in fact on May 23rd the
anti-corruption review was complete and
DOD certified to Congress
Ukraine had complied with all of the
conditions and that the remaining half
of the age should be released this was
confirmed by the June 18th press release
announcing the release or announcing the
the funding and do you remember the
fiction the fictitious quote-unquote
interagency review process
well that was made up - so no review was
necessary because it had already been
done next the President's Council keeps
saying this was about corruption in
Ukraine President Trump is not concerned
with fighting corruption it's difficult
to even say that with a straight face
the president never mentioned corruption
on either a call with President
Zielinski but let's go through the
evidence as we just discussed DoD had
already completed a review and concluded
that Ukraine had quote made sufficient
progress in meeting defense reform and
anti-corruption goals consistent with
the National Defense Authorization Act
in order to receive the funds and in
fact mark sandy who was not at that
meeting but who was initially
responsible for approving the hold said
he had never heard corruption as a
reason for the hold in all of the
discussions he had about it similar to
the anti-corruption argument there is
simply no evidence to support the
president's after-the-fact argument that
he was concerned about burden sharing
now that's other countries also
contributing to Ukraine
I imagine the president may cite the
emails in June about what other
countries provided to Ukraine the
reference to other countries
contributions in the July 25th call and
testimony from Sandy about a request for
information about what other European
countries give Ukraine but there is
simply no evidence that ties the concern
to his decision to hold the funding
first let's actually look at the
contributions of European countries to
Ukraine as a slide in front of you it
shows that other European countries have
significantly significantly contributed
to Ukraine since 2014 and the European
Union in total has given far
more than the u.s. the EU is the single
largest donor to Ukraine having provided
over 16 billion in grants and loans the
president's assertion that other
countries did not support Ukraine is
meritless and there are other reasons
too after DoD and OMB responded to the
President's request presumably with some
of the information we just provided you
showing Europe gives a lot to Ukraine
nobody in the Trump administration
mentioned burden-sharing as a reason for
the hold to any of the 17 witnesses that
we've been talking about Sandlin whose
actual portfolio is the EU not Ukraine
testified that he was never asked to
speak to the EU or e EU member countries
about providing more aid to Ukraine
and a president Trump were truly
concerned about that he would have been
the perfect guy to handle it because he
was our ambassador to the EU but it
never happened and how could it because
Sandlin himself knew the aid was linked
to the investigations because that's
what the President himself had told him
it wasn't until the president's scheme
began to unravel after the White House
learned of the whistleblower complaint
and after Politico publicly revealed the
existence of the hold that the issue of
burden-sharing came up again if the
president's concern were genuinely about
burden-sharing
he never made any public statements
about it never ordered a review of
burden-sharing and never ordered his
officials to push europe to increase
their contributions and then he released
the aid without any changes in Europe's
contributions this last point is
important you know the president
purported the president's purported
concern about burden-sharing rings
hollow because the aid was released
after the president got caught not
because the EU or any European country
made any new contributions as Lieutenant
Colonel venom intesifies the facts on
the ground had not changed finally you
may hear the president's counsel say
that Ukraine didn't know about the hold
until August 28th long after the hold
was implemented so therefore they
could not have felt pressure but this
makes no sense first they found out
about it long before August 28th
multiple witnesses testified that the
Ukrainians showed quote impressive
diplomatic tradecraft and learning
quickly about the hold and of course
they would know the DoD release was
announced in June and US agencies knew
about it in July so it should be no
surprise that the first enquiries about
the aid were on July 25th the same day
as the call you see it doesn't matter if
extortion lasts two weeks or two months
it's still extortion and Ukraine
certainly felt the pressure other
Ukrainian officials also expressed
concerns that the Ukrainian government
was being singled out and penalized for
some reason and they were by president
Trump and you know how else you know
they felt the pressure from the hold
because president szalinski finally
relented and was planning to do the CNN
interview ultimately right around the
time of president zelinsky's
conversation with Vice President or with
President Trump which is the subject of
the classified document that I urge all
senators to look at president szalinski
canceled the CNN interview but the
damage was already done the evidence is
clear the question for you is whether
it's okay for the president to withhold
taxpayer money aid for our ally our
friend at war for a personal political
benefit whether it's okay for the
president to sacrifice our national
security for his own election it's not
okay to me it's certainly not okay with
the American people and it should not be
okay to any of you
mr. Chief Justice distinguished members
of the Senate presidents Council the
American people once again we are
gathered here not as Democrats or
Republicans not as the left or the right
not as progressives or conservatives but
as Americans doing our constitutional
duty during this moment of presidential
accountability and as house managers we
thank you for your courtesy your
attentiveness and your hospitality at
the heart of Article two obstruction of
Congress is a simple troubling reality
president Trump tried to cheat he got
caught and then he worked hard to cover
it up the president tried to cheat he
got caught and then he worked hard to
cover it up Patrick Henry one of the
nation's great Patriots once said that
the liberties of a people never were nor
ever will be secure when the
transactions of their rulers may be
concealed from them
let's now address the effort by
President Trump and his team to cover up
his wrongdoing by July of 2019 White
House officials were aware of serious
allegations of misconduct by President
Trump
regarding Ukraine but instead of halting
the president's corrupt scheme they
worked overtime to conceal it from the
American people as additional evidence
of the president's wrongdoing mounted
White House lawyers redouble their
efforts to prevent Congress and the
American people from learning of the
president's misconduct at the same time
top administration officials including
Secretary of State Pompeo Secretary of
Defense
Esper and national security adviser John
Bolton tried to convince President Trump
to lift the hold on the security
assistance they failed president Trump
was determined to carry out his corrupt
scheme the military and security aid was
only released on September 11th after
the hold became public after the house
launched an investigation and after
Congress learned about the existence of
a whistleblower complaint the 391
million dollars in security aid was only
released because President Trump was
caught red-handed
the actions of President Trump and
high-level White House officials allowed
his abuse of power to continue beyond
the watchful eye of Congress and most
importantly the American people as we
have discussed at length on July 10th
ambassador Solomon told the Ukrainians
and other US officials that he had a
deal with acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney to schedule the White House
meeting President szalinski wanted if
the new Ukrainian leader committed to
the phony investigations that President
Trump sought as you've seen in testimony
shirring shown during this trial
following that meeting national security
council officials dr. Fiona Hill and
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
immediately reported this information to
John Eisenberg the legal adviser for the
National Security Council and a deputy
counsel to the president according to
dr. hill mr. Eisenberg told her that he
was also
about that July 10th meeting on the
screen is dr. Hills deposition testimony
where she explains mr. Eisenberg's
reaction saying I mean he wasn't aware
that Sunland ambassador Sunland was kind
of running around doing a lot of these
meetings and independently we talked
about the fact that ambassador Solomon
said he'd been meeting with Giuliani and
he was very concerned about that and he
said that he would follow up on this
daizen Berg was very concerned about
that and said that he would follow up on
this dr. hill further testified that mr.
Eisenberg told her that he followed up
with his boss the distinguished White
House Counsel Pat SIPP alone however
because the president blocked mr.
Eisenberg from testifying in the house
we do not know what if anything he or
mr. SIPP alone did in response to this
deeply troubling information what we do
know is that president Trump's effort to
cheat continued with reckless abandon by
failing to put the brakes on the
wrongdoing after that July 10th meeting
even afterward note after they were
notified by concern national security
officials the White House attorneys
allowed it to continue unchecked right
around the same time that July 10th
meetings at the White House took place
the Office of Management and Budget
began executing president Trump's
illegal order to withhold all security
assistance from Ukraine on July 12th
Robert Blair an assistant to the
president communicated the hold to the
acting director of the Office of
Management and Budget Russell Vaughn on
July
18th an Office of Management and Budget
official communicated the hold to other
executive branch agencies including the
Department of State and the Department
of Defense and a week later on July 25th
President Trump had his imperfect
telephone call with president Solinsky
and directly pressured the Ukrainian
leader to commence phony political
investigations as part of his effort to
cheat and solicit foreign interference
in a twenty20 election the July 25th
call marked an important turning point
if there was any question among senior
White House officials and attorneys
about whether President Trump was
directly involved in the Ukraine scheme
as opposed to just a rogue operation
being led by Rudolph Giuliani or some
other underlings after July 25th there
can be no mistake the President of the
United States was undoubtedly calling
the shots there after the complicity of
White House officials with respect to
the cover-up of the president's
misconduct intensified immediately after
the July 25th call both Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh and his direct
supervisor Tim Morrison reported their
concerns about the call to mr. Eisenberg
and his deputy Michael Ellis in fact
within an hour after the July 25th call
Lieutenant Colonel VIN men returned
again a second time to mr. Eisenberg and
reported his concerns
I was concerned by the call what I heard
was inappropriate and I afforded my
concerns to mr. Eisenberg it is improper
for the President of the United States
to demand a foreign government
investigate a US citizen and a political
opponent
I was also clear that if Ukraine pursued
an investigation it was it was also
clear that if Ukraine pursued an
investigation into the 2016 elections
the Biden's and briefs m'a it would be
interpreted as a partisan play this
would undoubtedly result in Ukraine
losing bipartisan support
undermining US national security and
inventing Russia's strategic objectives
in the reason region I want to emphasize
to the committee that when I record my
concerns of July 10th relating to
ambassador Solomon and then July 25th
relating to the president I did so out
of a sense of duty
I privately reported my concerns in
official channels to the proper
authority in the chain of command my
intent was to raise these concerns
because they had significant national
security implications for our country I
never thought that I'd be sitting here
testifying in front of this committee
and the American public about my actions
when I reported my concerns my only
thought was to act properly and to carry
out my duty timothy morrison the
national security council's senior
director for europe and russia also
reported the call to mr. Eisenberg and
asked him to review the call which he
feared would be damaging if leaked mr.
morrison shortly after you heard the
July 25th call you testified that you
alerted the NSC legal adviser John
Eisenberg pretty much right away is that
right correct
and you indicated in your opening
statement at least from your deposition
that you went to mr. Eisenberg out of
concern over the potential political
fallout if the call record became public
and not because you thought it was
illegal is that right correct but you
you would agree right that asking a
foreign government to investigate a
domestic
political rival is inappropriate would
you not it's not what is not what we
recommended the president discuss the
July 25th call was at least a second
time that National Security Council
officials have reported concerns about
president Trump's pressure campaign to
White House lawyers the second time who
now clearly understood the gravity of
the ongoing misconduct but because the
president blocked mr. Eisenberg from
testifying without any justification the
record is silent as to what if any
actions he well the White House Counsel
took to address president Trump's brazen
misconduct and abuse of power we do know
however that instead of trying to halt
the scheme White House lawyers
facilitated it by taking affirmative
steps to conceal evidence of president
Trump's misconduct
for example after lieutenant-colonel
binman and mr. Morrison reported their
concerns related to the July 25th call
to the National Security Council lawyers
they tried to bury the call summary they
tried to bury it ten eternal women
testified that the National Security
Council lawyers believed it was quote
appropriate to restrict access to the
call summary for the purpose of the
leaks and to preserve the integrity of
the transcript according to Lieutenant
Colonel vim and mr. Eisenberg gave the
go-ahead to restrict access to the call
summary mr. Morrison testified that he
learned in late August after he raised
concerns at the call record might leak
and politically damaged
president that the call summary had been
placed on a highly classified national
security council server the call record
was placed on a server that is reserved
for America's most sensitive national
security secrets and covert operations
not routine calls with foreign leaders
apparently mr. Eisenberg claimed the
time that burying the call transcript on
a highly classified server was a mistake
now in a second meeting with mr.
Eisenberg what did you recommend that he
do to prevent the call record from
leaking I recommended we restrict access
to the package had you ever asked the
NSC legal adviser to restrict access
before no did you speak to your
supervisor dr. Kupperman before you went
to speak to John Eisenberg no did you
subsequently learn that the call record
had been put in a highly classified
system I did and what reason did mr.
Eisenberg give you for why the call
record was put in the highly classified
system it was a mistake he said it was
just a mistake
it was an administrative error and mr.
Morrison's view the July 25th call
record did not meet the requirements to
be placed on a highly classified server
at his deposition Mr Morrison testified
that the call record was placed on the
server by mistake however even after
this alleged mistake was uncovered the
July 25th call summary was not removed
from the classified system because
someone was trying to hide it it was not
until the launch of the house
impeachment inquiry in late September
and after intense public
pressure that the rough transcript of
the July 25th call was released again
because mr. Eisenberg and mr. Ellis
refused to testify in the house we do
not know exactly how the July 25th call
record ended up on this highly
classified National Security Council
server what we do know is that mr.
Eisenberg ordered access restricted
after multiple officials like dr. Fiona
Hill and Lieutenant Colonel bin Minh
advised him of the scheme to condition a
White House meeting on phony political
investigations this strongly suggests
that there was an active attempt to
conceal the clear evidence of the
president's wrongdoing instead of
addressing the president's misconduct
mr. Eisenberg seemingly tried to cover
it up why did mr. Eisenberg place the
July 25th call summary on a server for
highly classified material did anyone
senior - mr. Eisenberg direct him to
hide the call record why did the call
record remain on the classified server
even after the so called
error was discovered who ordered the
cover-up of the call record
who ordered the cover-up of the call
record the American people deserve to
know following July 25th call the
president scheme to pressure Ukraine for
political purposes intensified
apparently unchecked by any effort to
stop it from the White House counsel's
office after the July 25th call
ambassador Solomon and Volcker worked
with the president's personal lawyer
Rudolph Giuliani to procure a public
statement from President szalinski
to announce phony investigations into
Joe Biden and the crowd strike
conspiracy theory being peddled by
President Trump at the same time
president Trump continued to withhold
the White House meeting and security
assistance from Ukraine in a manner that
broke the law as these efforts were
ongoing White House attorneys reportedly
received yet another warning sign that
the president was abusing his power
according to a published report in The
New York Times the week after July 25th
call an anonymous whistleblower reported
concerns that the president was abusing
his office for personal gain the
whistleblower complaint landed in the
CIA general counsel's office although
the concerns related directly to the
president's own misconduct
the CIA's general counsel Courtney
Elwood alerted mr. Eisenberg over the
next week miss Elwood mr. Eisenberg and
their deputies reportedly discussed the
whistleblowers concerns and they
determined as required by law
that the allegations had a reasonable
basis so by early August White House
lawyers began working along with
attorneys at the Department of Justice
to cover-up the president's wrongdoing
they were determined to prevent Congress
and the American people from learning
anything about the president's corrupt
behavior although senior
Justice Department officials including
attorney general bill Barr were
reportedly made aware of the concerns
about corrupt activity no investigation
into president Trump's wrongdoing was
even open by the Department of Justice
as White House and Justice Department
lawyers were discussing how to deal with
the whistle
as concerns on August 12th another
important date the whistleblower filed a
formal complaint with the Inspector
General for the intelligence community
in accordance with federal law on August
26 the Inspector General transmitted the
whistleblower complaint to the Acting
Director of National Intelligence Joseph
Maguire along with the Inspector
General's preliminary conclusion that
the complaint was both credible and
related to a matter of urgent concern
urgent concern but instead of
transmitting the whistleblower complaint
to the house and to this Senate's
distinguished Intelligence Committee as
required by law the Acting Director of
National Intelligence notified the White
House well director I'm just I'm still
trying to rest endocrinology so you
first went the office of legal counsel
and then you went to White House Counsel
we went into the repeat that please sir
I'm just trying to send the chronology
you first went to the office of legal
counsel and then you went to the White
House Counsel no don't no sir no sir no
we went to the went to the White House
first to determine to ask okay that's
all I want to know is granola so you
went to the White House first so you
went to the subject of the complaint for
advice first about whether you should
provide the complaint to Congress there
were issues within this a couple of
things one it did appear that it has
executive privilege if it does have
executive privilege it is the White
House that determines that I cannot
determine that as the Director of
National Intelligence
under federal law the Acting Director of
National Intelligence was required to
share the whistleblower complaint with
Congress . . if that had occurred the
president's scheme to withhold security
assistance and a White House meeting
being sought by the new Ukrainian leader
to pressure Ukraine for his own personal
political gain would have been exposed
to prevent that from happening
the president's lawyers and top-level
advisors adopted a two-prong cover-up
strategy first blocked Congress and the
American people from learning about the
whistleblower complaint second try to
convince President Trump to lift the
hold on the Security Assistance before
anyone can find out about it and use
that evidence against them as to the
first prong sometime after the Acting
Director of National Intelligence told
the White House counsel's office about
the complaint on August 26th mr. sip
alone and mr. Eisenberg reportedly
briefed the president they likely
discussed with President Trump whether
they were legally required to give the
complaint to Congress they stated that
they were consulting with the Office of
Legal Counsel at the Department of
Justice the Acting Director of National
Intelligence testified that he and
Inspector General consulted with the
Office of Legal Counsel who opined
without any reasonable basis that he did
not have to turn over the complaint to
Congress on September 3rd the day after
the statutory deadline for the Director
of National Intelligence to provide the
complaint to this body and to the house
the office of legal counsel issued a
secret opinion concluding that contrary
to the plain language of the statute the
Acting Director of National Intelligence
was not required to turn over the
complaint the cover-up was in full swing
the office of legal counsel opined that
the whistleblower complaint did not
qualify as an urgent concern and
therefore did not have to be turned over
what can be more urgent than a sitting
president trying to cheat in an American
election by soliciting foreign
interference what can be more urgent
than that that's a constitutional crime
in progress but they concluded it wasn't
an urgent matter Acting Director of
National Intelligence McGuire testified
that the office of legal counsel opinion
did not actually prevent him from
turning over the complaint to Congress
instead based upon his testimony it is
clear that he withheld it on the basis
that the complaint might deal with
information that he believed could be
covered by executive privilege but
President Trump never actually invoked
executive privilege he never actually
invoked executive privilege nor did he
informed Congress that he was doing so
with respect to this complaint instead
the White House secretly instructed the
Acting Director of National Intelligence
so withhold the complaint based on the
mere possibility that executive
privilege could be invoked by doing so
the White House was able to keep the
explosive complaint from Congress and
the American public without ever having
to disclose
the reason why it was withholding this
information but truth crushed to the
ground will rise again there's a toxic
mess at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue and I
humbly suggests that it's our collective
job on behalf of the American people to
try to clean it up President Trump tried
to cheat he got caught and then he
worked hard to cover it up there have
been many great presidents throughout
the history of this Republic great
Republican presidents and great
Democratic presidents perhaps one of the
greatest presidents is Abraham Lincoln
he once said that any man can handle
adversity but if you want to test the
man's character give them some power
America is a great nation we can handle
adversity better than any other country
in the world
whenever America has found itself in a
tough spot we always make it to the
other side we were in a tough spot
during the Civil War when America was at
risk of tearing itself apart but we made
it to the other side a tough spot in
October of 1929 when the stock market
collapsed plunging us into the great
depression but we made it to the other
side we were in a tough spot in December
of 1941 when a foreign power struck
plunging us into a great conflict with
the evil empire of Nazi Germany but
America
to the other side we were in a tough
spot in the 1960s dealing with the
inherent contradictions of Jim Crow but
we made it to the other side we were in
a tough spot on September 11th when the
towers were struck and young men and
women like Jason Crowe was sent to
Afghanistan to fight the terrorists
there so we didn't have to fight the
terrorists here and we made it to the
other side America is a great country we
can handle adversity better than any
other nation in the world but what are
we going to do about our character
president Trump tried to cheat and
solicit foreign interference in an
American election that is an attack on
our character
president Trump abused his power and
corrupted the highest office in the land
that is an attack on our character
president Trump tried to cover it all up
and hide it from the American people and
obstruct Congress that's an
extraordinary attack on our character
America is a great nation we can handle
adversity better than any other country
in the world but what are we going to do
about our character
crisis around the president's hold
deepened throughout our government the
president's own top advisors redoubled
their efforts to lift the hold on
military aid in stem the fallout in case
it went public and it did go public on
August 28th Politico publicly reported
that the president was withholding the
military aid and as you've heard the
public disclosure of the president's
hold in late August cause deep alarm
among Ukrainian officials it also caused
US officials to redouble their efforts
once again at the end of August
Secretary of State Pompeo defense
secretary s per annum and ambassador
Bolton reportedly tried to convince
President Trump to release the aid but
they failed the president wanted the
hold to remain that prompted Duffy the
political appointee charged with
implementing the hold to send an email
on August 30th to the DoD stating and I
quote clear direction from POTUS to hold
now this is consistent with Laura
Cooper's deposition testimony when she
said that they were quote hopeful this
whole time that secretary asper and
secretary Pompeo would be able to meet
with the president and just explained to
him why this was so important and get
the funds released but instead the
president held firm and even as the
president's own cabinet officials were
trying to convince him to lift the hold
White House lawyers were receiving new
reports about their president's abuse on
September first vice president pence met
with President Solinsky in Warsaw and
immediately after Sandlin had a side
conversation with the top Ukrainian
presidential aide Morrison was privy to
these conversations and when he returned
from Warsaw he reported to Eisenberg the
details
what did ambassador sunland say to tell
you that he told mr.
that the Ukrainians would have to have
the prosecutor general make a statement
with respect to the investigations as a
condition of having the aid lifted you
testified that you were not comfortable
with what ambassador Sandlin had told
you why not well I was concerned about
what I saw as essentially an additional
hurdle to accomplishing what I had been
directed to to help accomplish which was
giving the president the information he
needed to determine that the security
sector assistance could go forward so
now there's a whole other wrinkle to it
right there was the appearance of one
based on what ambassador Solomon
represented and you told ambassador
Taylor about this conversation as well
is that right
I I promptly reached out to ambassador
Taylor to schedule a secure phone call
and in your deposition you testified
that his testimony other than one small
distinction between president Solinsky
and the prosecutor general was accurate
as to what you told him
is that correct about that conversation
yes and generally speaking you confirmed
everything that ambassador Taylor told
you except for that one thing in a small
other ministerial matter relating to the
location of a meeting is that correct
correct
now did you tell the ambassador bolton
about this conversation as well I've
reached out to him as well and requested
his availability for a secure phone call
and what was his response when you
explained to him what ambassador Sandlin
had said tell the lawyers did you go
tell the lawyers when I returned to the
States yes and did he explain to you why
he wanted you to tell the lawyers he did
not how this wasn't the first time and
it wouldn't be the last that ambassador
Bolton instructed other government
officials to report details of the
president's scheme to White House
lawyers now let's be clear when
government employees have concerns about
whether something is legal they often go
to their agency's lawyers and it was
happening an awful lot around this time
recall that Bolton also instructed dr.
Hill to report to the lawyer's Sandlin
statements about requiring an
announcement of the investigations as a
condition for a White House meeting
what Bolden called sunland's quote drug
deal with the president's top aide Mick
Mulvaney ambassador Bolton's testimony
would obviously shine further light on
these concerns in what or who if anyone
at the White House or the cabinet did to
try to stop the president at this time
after the president's hold and military
aid became public in late August there
was increasing pressure on the President
to lift the hole on September 3rd a
bipartisan group of senators sent a
letter to acting White House chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney an excerpt from that
letter is in front of you
the senator has expressed quote deep
concerns that the quote administration
is considering not obligating the
Ukraine Security Initiative funds for
2019 the Senators letter also urged that
the vital funds be obligated immediately
on September 5th the Chairman and the
ranking member of the House Foreign
Affairs Committee sent a joint letter to
Mulvaney and OMB director Russell Vaughn
that letter also expressed deep concern
about the continuing hold on the
military aid the same day senators
Murphy and Johnson visited Kiev and met
with President Solinsky along with
ambassador Taylor on September 5th I
accompanied senators Johnson and Murphy
during their visit to Keefe when we met
with President Solinsky his first
question to the Senators was about the
withheld security assistance my
recollection of the meeting is that both
centers as stressed that bipartisan
support for Ukraine in Washington was
Ukraine's most important strategic asset
and that presidents olinsky's should not
jeopardize that bipartisan support by
getting drawn in to u.s. domestic
politics I had been making and continue
to make this point to all of my official
Ukrainian contacts but the odd push to
make president szalinski publicly commit
to investigations of Burris m'a and
alleged in
in the 2016 election showed how the
official foreign policy of the United
States was undercut by the irregular
efforts led by mr. Giuliani the senator
sought to reassure President szalinski
that there was bipartisan support in
Congress for providing the military aid
also on September 5th the Washington
Post editorial board reported concerns
that President Trump was withholding the
eight and a meeting to force President
szalinski to announce investigations to
benefit his personal political campaign
the editors wrote quote were reliably
told that the president has a second and
more venal agenda he is attempting to
force mr. szalinski to intervene in the
2020 u.s. presidential election by
launching an investigation of the
leading Democratic candidate Joe bide
mr. Trump is not just soliciting
Ukraine's help with his presidential
campaign he is using US military aid the
country desperately needs in an attempt
to extort it in quote despite these
efforts to get the President to lift the
hold in the now public discussion about
the president's abuse of power the
scheme continued two days later on
September 7th Morrison went back to
White House lawyers to report additional
details he had learned from ambassador
Sandlin about the president's scheme
again at the direction of ambassador
Bolton now a few days later on September
7th you spoke again to Ambassador
Sandlin who told you that he had just
gotten off the phone with President
Trump isn't that right that sounds
correct yes
what did ambassador Sandlin tell you
that President Trump said to him if I
recall this conversation correctly this
was where ambassador Salman related that
there was no quid pro quo but President
Solinsky had to make the statement and
that he had to want to do it and
by that point did you understand that
the statement related to the Biden into
2016 investigations I think I did yes
and that that was essentially a
condition for the Security Assistance to
be released
I understood that that's what ambassador
Saldana believed after speaking with
President Trump that's what he
represented now you testified that
hearing this information gave you a
sinking feeling well why was that well I
believe if we're all in September 7 the
end of the fiscal year September 30th
these are one-year dollars of the DoD
and the Department of State funds so we
only had so much time and in fact
because Congress imposed a 15-day
notification requirement on the State
Department funds September 7th September
30th that really means September 15th in
order to secure a decision from the
President to allow the funds to go
forward did you tell ambassador bolton
about this conversation as well I did
yes and what did he say to you he said
to tell the lawyers and why did he say
to tell the lawyers he did not explain
his instruction again tell the lawyers
ambassador sunland's call with President
Trump on September 7th also prompted
deep concern by ambassador Taylor which
you've already heard about on September
8th and 9th ambassador Taylor exchanged
whatsapp messages with ambassador
Sandlin and Volker describing his quote
nightmare scenario that quote they give
the interview and don't get the security
assistance as he then goes on to say
quote the Russians love it and I quit
after the hold in the military aid
became public the White House took two
actions in early September first the
White House in the Justice Department
ensured that the acting D and I
continued to withhold the whistleblower
complaint from Congress in clear
violation of the law and second the
White House attempted to create a cover
story for the president's withholding of
the assistance approximately two months
after President Trump had ordered the
freeze
mark sandy received an email from his
boss Michael Duffy that for the first
time gave a reason for the whole sandy
testified that in early September he
received an email from Duffy quote that
attributed the hole to the president's
concern about other countries not
contributing more to Ukraine again after
months of scrambling this was the first
time any reason had been provided for
the hole and according to Sandy it was
also only in early September again after
the White House learned to the
whistleblower complaint in the hold
became public that the White House
requested data from OMB on other
countries assistance to Ukraine so let's
recap why we know the concern about
burden sharing was bogus first four
months no reason was given to the very
people executing the military aid who
had been actively searching for answers
about why the aid was being held second
remember the supposed interagency
process performed by OMB well it was
fake and third after the hold went
public and the White House became aware
of the whistleblower they started
scrambling to develop another excuse
public reports confirm this a November
24th news report for instance revealed
that in September mr. Sibal oneis
lawyers conducted an internal records
review the review reportedly quote
turned up hundreds of documents that
reveal extensive efforts to generate an
after-the-fact justification for the
decision in a debate over whether the
delay was legal the president's top
aides were trying to convince the
president to lift the hold in late
August and early September and White
House officials were actively working to
develop an excuse for the president's
scheme and devise a cover story in the
event that it was exposed and soon it
would be on September 9th the chairs of
the House Intelligence Committee the
Committee on Foreign Affairs in the
comedian Oversight and Reform publicly
announced the joint investigation of
President Trump in mr. Giuliani scheme
and this is when the music stops
and everyone starts running to find a
chair word of the committee's
investigation spread quickly through the
White House to the NSC Morrison recalled
seeing and discussing the letter with
NSE staff lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh
also recalled discussions among NSC
staff members including Morrison's
deputy Jonna Rath about the
investigation the same day there were
efforts at OMB to create a paper trail
that tried to shift the blame for the
president's hold on security assistance
away from the White House Duffy send an
email to Elaine mckusker that
contradicted months of email exchanges
it stated falsely that OMB had in fact
authorized DoD to proceed with all
process necessary to obligate funds
Duffy was attempting to shift all the
responsibility for the delay on to the
Pentagon mckusker replied and I quote
you can't be serious I am speechless now
all of this including OMB efforts to
shift blame to the Pentagon the White
House's effort to create a cover story
for the hold on security assistance were
a continuation of the cover-up it
started with the White House's lawyers
failure to stop the scheme after the
July 10th meeting was reported to them
continued with attempts to hide the July
25th call summary and escalated with the
White House's illegal concealment of the
whistleblower complaint from Congress on
September 10th the House Intelligence
Committee requested that the DNI provide
a copy of the whistleblower complaint as
the law requires but Dee and I continued
to withhold the complaint for weeks the
same day it was announced that
ambassador Bolton was resigning or had
been fired it is unclear whether
ambassadors Bolden ambassador Bolton's
departure from the White House had
anything to do with his opposition to
the hold on military aid but of course
ambassador Bolton could shed light on
that himself if he were to testify
the next day on September 11th president
Trump met with vice president pence
Mulvaney and Senator Portman to discuss
the hold later that day the president
relented and lifted the hold after a
scheme had been exposed the president's
decision to release the aide just like
his decision to impose the hold was
never explained cooper testified the
president Trump's lifting of the hold
quote really came out of the blue it was
quite abrupt the only logical conclusion
based on all of this evidence is that
the president lifted the hold on
September 11th because he got caught the
president's decision to lift the hold
without any explanation is also very
telling if the hold was put in place for
legitimate policy reasons why lifted
arbitrarily with no explanation by
lifting the hold only after Congress had
launched an investigation when as
Lieutenant Colonel of Inman testified
none of the facts on the ground had
changed since the hold have been put
into place the president was conceding
that there was never a legitimate
purpose since the hold was lifted the
president had pay has paid lip service
to purported concerns about corruption
in burden-sharing but the administration
has taken no concrete steps before or
since those statements were made to show
that it really cares the record is clear
before he got caught the President had
no interest in anti-corruption reforms
in Ukraine and as you've already learned
those people who really were concerned
about these issues like Congress this
Senate the DoD in the State Department
had already gone through the process to
address them as ambassador sunland
testified at no point did the president
ask him to discuss additional
contributions to Ukraine from EU
countries nor did President Trump push
Ukraine to undertake any specific
anti-corruption reforms now the
President's Council will likely say that
his lifting of the hold shows his good
faith they will say that because Ukraine
ultimately received the aid without
president szalinski having to
announced the sham investigations that
there was no abuse of power as a legal
matter the fact that the president's
corrupt scheme was not fully successful
makes no difference
Trump's abuse occurred at the moment he
used the power of the presidency to
assist his reelection campaign
undermining our free and fair elections
and our national security but
importantly President Trump almost did
get away with it as discussed earlier
president szalinski agreed during his
September phone call with ambassador
Sandlin to do a CNN interview during
which he denounced the investigations on
September 12th ambassador Taylor
personally informed president szalinski
and the Ukrainian foreign minister that
president Trump's hold on military
assistance had been lifted and on
September 13th ambassador Taylor and
David Holmes met with President
Zielinski and his advisors and urged
them not to go forward with the CNN
interview it was not until September
18th and 19th around the time the
president szalinski spoke with vice
president pence that the Ukrainians
finally canceled the CNN interview the
president has also repeatedly pointed to
president solinsky's public statements
that he did not feel pressured by Trump
not only unsurprising it's also
irrelevant the question is whether
President Trump used the power of the
presidency to coerce President szalinski
into helping him win a political
campaign but we know that president
szalinski was pressure
he kept delaying in delaying because he
did not want to be a pawn in US domestic
politics in fact president szalinski
remains under president pressure to this
day as Holmes testified there are still
things the Ukrainians want and need from
the United States including a meeting
with the president in the Oval Office
which has still not been scheduled and
yes Ukraine remains at war in needs US
military aid including
that is still delayed from last year for
these reasons mr. Holmes explained quote
I think the Ukrainians are being very
careful
they still need us now going forward in
fact right now President szalinski is
trying to arrange a summit meeting with
President Putin in the coming weeks
his first face-to-face meeting with him
to try to advance the peace process he
needs our support
he needs President Putin to understand
that America supports Solinsky at the
highest levels so this doesn't end with
the lifting of the security assistance
hold Ukraine still needs us and as I
said still fighting this war this very
day when President Trump for his own
personal political gain asked for a
favor from President Solinsky he did
exactly what the framers feared most he
invited the influence of a foreign power
into our elections he used the power of
his office to secure that advantage in
jeopardized our national security yet
President Trump maintains that he was
always in the right and that is July
25th call with president szalinski was
perfect
president Trump has made it clear that
he believes he is free to use his powers
the same way to the same ends whenever
and wherever he pleases and even more
troubling he's even doubling down on his
view abuse inviting other countries to
interfere in our elections what does all
of this tell you it tells you that
ambassador Sandlin was correct when he
told Holmes after hanging up with
President Trump on July 26 that the
president doesn't care about Ukraine he
only cares about the quote big stuff
meaning stuff that helps him personally
the bottom line is that the president
used the powers of his office for
personal political gain he did so
knowing
deliberately and repeatedly and his
misconduct continues to this day
senators just for your orientation this
will be the last presentation on article
one and mr. leader I think at the
conclusions presentation will be a
logical point to take a break this last
section on article 1 deals with the
injury to our national interest and our
national security the president Trump
used Ukraine's leader for a political
favor and withheld critical military aid
to an ally in exchange for that favor he
did exactly what our framers feared most
he invited foreign interference in our
elections and sold out our country's
security for his personal benefit and
betrayed the nation's trust to a foreign
power the president schemed to pressure
Ukraine to do his political dirty work
harmed our national security
undermined our free and fair elections
and even today even today threatens the
very foundation of our democracy when
the president argues that his call was
perfect that he did nothing wrong what
he's really saying is that there's
nothing wrong with the president asking
a foreign government to do a personal
favor if there's nothing wrong with the
president pressuring that foreign
country to interfere in our elections
for his personal benefit that there's
nothing wrong with withholding
congressionally appropriated
taxpayer-funded military assistance to
that foreign country to extort that
country to help the president cheat to
win an election
but there are great many things wrong
with that most significant for the
purposes that bring us here today the
Constitution does not permit it and the
Constitution does not permit it because
that conduct is the quintessential abuse
of power the use of official power for
personal gain putting personal interest
over the national interest and placing
personal benefits over our nation's
security the president's conduct that we
outlined yesterday harmed our national
security that is without a doubt it
endangered our elections and it sent our
country on a dangerous path that if left
unchecked will cause irrevocable damage
to the balance of power contemplated in
our Constitution
if someone sacrifices the national
interest in favor of his own and is not
removed from office our democracy is in
jeopardy it's just that simple the grave
consequences of president Trump's
misconduct demand our attention let me
take these issues in turn beginning with
this harm to national security
first the president's abuse of power had
immediate consequences to our security
Ukraine is a burgeoning democracy
entangled in a hot war with Russia by
withholding military aid President Trump
not only denied Ukraine much-needed
military equipment but also weakened
Ukraine's position in negotiations over
the end of the war with Russia because
of presence from president Trump's
corrupt actions Vladimir Putin was
embolden at a pivotal moment ahead of
those sensitive negotiations to attempt
to end the war and embolden Russia is a
threat to the United States and global
security around the world the
president's willingness to put himself
over country undercut our European
allies confidence in America's
commitment to deterring Russian
aggression and its signaled to
adversaries and friends alike that the
President of the United States the most
powerful man in the world our
commander-in-chief could be influenced
by manipulating his perception of what
was best for his personal interests now
I have no doubt that the Russians and
probably every other nation that has the
capacity does a psychological profile of
the President of the United States as we
profile other leaders
if a present can be so easily
manipulated to disbelieve his own
intelligence agencies to accept the
propaganda of the Kremlin that is a
threat to our national security
and that is just what has happened here
but that's not all present trumps
willingness to entangle our foreign
allies in a corrupt political errand
also undermined the credibility of
Americans to promote the rule of law and
fight corruption abroad this is Trump
first not American first not American
ideals first and that result has and
will continue to be grave harm to our
nation
if this chamber does not stand up and
say it is wrong if you do not stand up
and say this is not only wrong not only
unacceptable but conduct incompatible
with the office of the presidency and if
it really is incompatible with the
office of the presidency if you cannot
faithfully execute that responsibility
if you cannot bring yourself to put your
nations interests ahead of your own
it must be impeachable or the nation
remains at risk let's consider the big
picture here and probably a question
many people around the country are
asking why it is Ukraine matter to the
United States
why does Ukraine matter of the United
States because we're talking about a
small country many people know very
little about
well this small country this ally of
ours is a country hungry for a reform
and eager for a stronger relation with
its most empower 'fl important ally the
United States
and we're talking about ourselves and
what it means the strength of our own
democracy and democracies around the
world when in countries like Ukraine are
fighting our fight against
authoritarianism at least that used to
be our fight and God help us if it's not
our fight
still Russian President Putin declared
the collapse of the Soviet Union to be
the greatest geopolitical catastrophe of
the 20th century Ukraine's vote for
independence in December 1991 was the
final nail in the Soviet Union's coffin
that made Ukraine's greatest moment
Putin's greatest tragedy when it
declared independence from Soviet
domination Ukraine inherited roughly
nineteen hundred Soviet nuclear warheads
enough firepower to level every a major
American city several times over
nineteen hundred Soviet nuclear warheads
in exchange for Ukraine surrendering
this Arsenal the United States Russia
and the United Kingdom reached an
understanding called the Budapest
memorandum of 1994 they continued they
committed in this memorandum to
respecting the borders of an independent
Ukraine and also to refrain from using
the threat or use of force against
Ukraine this was an early success of the
post Cold War period despite its
commitment to respect Ukraine's
independence of course Russia continued
to meddle in Ukraine's affairs
ambassador Taylor recounted how events
took an even more sinister turn in 2013
the West but in 2013
Vladimir Putin was so threatened by the
prospect of Ukraine joining the European
Union that he tried to bribe the
Ukrainian president this triggered mass
protests in the winter of 2013 that
drove
the Pratt that president to flee to
Russia in 2014 February 2014 but not
before his forces killed a hundred
Ukrainian protesters in central Kiev
angered by the fall of the Kremlin
backed leader in keeve President Putin
ordered the invasion of Ukraine
specifically a region known as Crimea
Russia's aggression was met with global
condemnation
we liked the sound there but you can see
the images of that conflict on the
screens before you Deputy Assistant
Secretary of Defense Laura Cooper
testified as to the stakes for US
national security Russia violated the
sovereignty of Ukraine's territory
Russia illegally annexed territory that
belonged to Ukraine they also denied
Ukraine access to its naval fleet at the
time and to this day Russia is building
a capability on Crimea designed to
expand Russian military power projection
far beyond the immediate region in 2014
were there concerns in Washington here
in Washington and European capitals that
Russia might not stop in Ukraine I was
not in my current position in 2014 but
it is my understanding that there was
significant fear about where a Russian
aggression would stop one American a war
hero and statesman who is no stranger to
this body recognized the threat posed by
Russia's invasion of Crimea Senator John
McCain in an interview he declared quote
we are all Ukrainians Senator McCain
advised that this is a chess match
reminiscent of the Cold War and we need
to realize that and act accordingly he
was of course absolutely right
consistent with the commitments made to
Ukraine in 1994 the United States and
Europe responded to Russia's invasion by
imposing significant sanctions on Russia
we joined Europe and providing Ukraine
billions of dollars in economic support
to help it resist Russian influence and
the Senate approved by an overwhelming
bipartisan majority vital security
assistance to help rebuild Ukraine's
military which the former Russian backed
leader of Ukraine had starved of
resources
this strong bipartisan support for
Ukraine reflected what Senator McCain
said was an opportunity for the United
States to undermine Russian leverage in
Eastern Europe by building quote a
success in Ukraine Senator McCain
outlined this vision putin also sees
here's this beautiful and large and
magnificent country called Ukraine and
suppose Ukraine finally after failing in
2004 gets it right democracy gets rid of
corruption economies really improving
and it's right there on the border of
Russia and so I think it makes him very
nervous if there were a success in
Ukraine in bringing about a free and
open society and economic success which
is not the case in Russia as you know
which is propped up by energy achieving
the Ukrainians success that Senator
McCain and many of us hoped for proved
to be a daunting task but several
witnesses have testified before the
House said Vladimir zelinsky's landslide
election in April 2019 was a game
changer here is how US diplomat David
Holmes explained the quote historic
opportunity created by his election
despite the Russian aggression over the
past five years Ukrainians have rebuilt
a shattered economy adhered to a peace
process and moved economically and
socially closer to the west toward our
way of life earlier this year large
majorities of Ukrainians again chose a
fresh start by voting for a political
newcomer as president replacing 80% of
their Parliament endorsing a platform
consistent with our democratic values
our forum priorities and our strategic
interests this year's revolution at the
ballot box underscores the despite its
imperfections Ukraine is a genuine and
vibrant democracy and an example to
other post-soviet countries and beyond
from Moscow to Hong Kong support for
Ukraine's security and reform
is critical not only to our own national
security but that to other allies and
emerging democracies around the world
the widely accepted fact of Ukraine's
importance to our national security
makes president Trump's abuse of power
and withholding of vital diplomatic and
military support all the more disturbing
first witnesses assess that withholding
the military aid likely helped to
prolong the war against Russia when wars
dragged on more people died ambassador
Taylor testified to this sober reality I
take it if the provision of the US
military assistance would save Ukrainian
lies lives that any delay and that
assistance may also cost Ukrainian lives
is that is that true mister of course
it's hard to provoke to draw any direct
lines between any particular element of
security systems and any particular
death on the battlefield but it is
certainly true that that assistance had
enabled Ukrainian armed forces to be
effective at deter and to be able to
take countermeasures to the to the
attacks that the Russians had and I
think you said that a Ukrainian soldier
lost their life while you were visiting
Dumbo's we keep very careful track of
the casualties and I noticed on the next
day the the information that we got that
one was killed four people before
soldiers were wounded on that day and
indeed Ukrainians lose their lives every
week every week David Holmes also
testified that prolonging the war in
Ukraine results in additional casualties
as we sit here today Ukrainians are
fighting a hot war on Ukrainian
territory against Russian aggression
this week alone since I have been here
in Washington two Ukrainian soldiers
were killed and two injured by Russian
LED forces in eastern Ukraine despite a
declared ceasefire I learned overnight
that seven more were injured yesterday
with holding the aid has real
consequences to real soldiers
real families and bear in mind that US
aid is fully 10% of Ukraine's defense
budget 10% that's not an extra bonus
that's necessary aid for Ukraine to
defend itself on the frontline now a
second consequence of president Trump's
withholding a military assistance was
that an emboldened Russia our adversary
here is Laura Cooper a Pentagon official
who oversaw the military aid what what
what about today if the US were to
withdraw its military support of Ukraine
what would effectively happen it is my
belief that if we were to withdraw our
support it would embolden Russia
it would also validate Russia's
violation of international law and which
country stands to benefit the most would
stand to benefit the most from such a
withdrawal
Russia Russia was not only embattled
emboldened on the battlefield ambassador
Taylor testified that president Trump's
corrupt withholding and military
assistance and as failure to host
president Solinsky in the Oval Office
was quote a sign of weakness to Moscow
and it harmed Ukraine's negotiating
position even as recently as December 9
when Zielinski and Putin met to discuss
the conflict in the East shown in this
photo ambassador Taylor explained I
think you also testify that Russia was
watching closely to gauge the level of
Americans support for the Ukrainian
government why is that significant this
is significant mr. chairman because the
Ukrainians in particular under this new
administration are eager to end this war
and they are eager to end it in a way
that there that the Russians leave their
territory these negotiations like all
negotiations are difficult Ukrainians
would like to be able to the
from a from a position of strength or at
least more strength than they now have
part of that strength part of the
ability of the Ukrainians to negotiate
against the Russians with the Russians
for for an end to the war in Davos
depends on United States and other
international support if we withdraw or
suspend or or threaten to withdraw our
security systems that's a message to the
Ukrainians but it's at least as
important as your question indicates mr.
chairman to the Russians who are looking
for any sign of weakness or any sign
that we are withdrawing our support for
Ukraine and so when the Ukrainians
learned of the suspension of the
military aid either privately or when
others learn publicly the Russians would
be learning also and they would take
that as a lack of robust US support for
Ukraine is that right that's correct sir
and that would weaken Ukraine in
negotiating an end to the war in Donbass
it would indeed the aid doesn't just
supply much needed weapons to Ukraine it
is a symbol of support a signal of
strength a signal of the backing of the
United States and withholding that aid
even for a period of time undermined all
of those things president Trump's
actions towards Ukraine also undercut
worldwide confidence in the United
States as a reliable security partner
maintaining that confidence is crucial
to the strength of our alliances in
Europe to deterring Russia and
ultimately protecting and projecting
democracy around the world the United
States has roughly 68,000 troops
stationed in Europe they serve alongside
troops from 28 other countries that
comprise the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization or NATO
they are holding the line against
further Russian aggression it was us
leadership that led to the creation of
NATO's 70 years ago as the Iron Curtain
was descending across the heart of
Europe and it is American leadership
that makes NATO work today NATO is also
affected because other countries friends
and foes alike know that we are
committed to our collective defence that
an attack against one nation is an
attack against all of us
that principle deterred a Russian
invasion of Europe during the Cold War
it's only been invoked once by NATO in
the aftermath of the September 11th
terrorist attacks New York is a long way
from the frontlines with Russia but our
European allies stood with us after that
dark day they deployed tens of thousands
of troops to Afghanistan and joined us
in fighting the al-qaeda terrorists who
attacked the Twin Towers and the
Pentagon now Ukraine is not a member of
NATO but Russia's invasion of Ukraine it
was a threat to the peace and security
of Europe Moscow's aggression threatened
the rules of the road that have kept the
peace in Europe since World War two the
sacrosanct idea that borders cannot be
changed by military force if we had not
supported Ukraine in 2014 if members of
this body had not voted overwhelmingly
on a bipartisan basis for military
assistance to rebuild Ukraine's military
there was no question it would have
invited further Russian adventurism in
Ukraine and perhaps elsewhere in the
heart of Europe it would have weakened
our allies and exposed us troops
stationed in Europe to greater danger
deterring Russia requires persistence
not just one military aid package or one
oval office meeting but a sustained
policy of support for our partners we
only deter Russia by consistently
demonstrating support for our friends
friends like Ukraine George Shultz who
serve as Ronald Reagan's Secretary of
State understood this he compared
diplomacy and alliance management to
gardening he said quote if you plant a
garden and go away for six months what
have you got when you come back weeds
diplomacy he said is kind of
like that you go around talk to people
you develop a relationship of trust and
confidence and then if something comes
up you have that base to work from
president Trump's decision to transform
the military aid and oval office meeting
into leverage was the equivalent of
trampling all over George Shultz garden
crushing Ukraine's confidence in the
United States as a partner he also
caused our NATO allies to question
whether we would stand with them against
Russia leaders in European capitals now
wonder whether personal political favors
and not treaty obligations guide our
foreign policy colleagues this is how
alliances wither and die and how Russia
wins ambassador Taylor made clear that
is why it is so important to our
security that we stand with Ukraine mr.
chairman as as my colleague deputy
secretary George Kent described we have
a national security policy a national
defense policy that identifies Russia
and China as adversaries the Russians
are violating all of the rules treaties
understandings that they committed to
that actually kept the peace in Europe
for nearly 70 years until they invaded
Ukraine in 2014 they had abided by
sovereignty of sovereignty of nations of
inviability of borders that rule of law
that order that kept the peace in Europe
and allowed for prosperity as well as
peace in Europe was violated by the
Russians and if we don't push back on
that on those violations then that will
continue and that mr. chairman affects
us it affects the world that we live in
that our children will grow up in and
our grand job this affects the kind of
world that we want to to see evolve so
that affects our national interest very
directly Ukraine is on the front line of
that of that conflict now we understood
that in 2017 the first year of the Trump
administration and it appeared the Trump
administration understood it as well and
we understood it in 2018 and the Trump
administration understood that as well
and we understood that in 2019 and the
Trump administration appeared to as well
at least it did until it didn't it did
until something of greater importance
and significance came along and that
event of greater significance to the
Oval Office was the emergence of Joe
Biden as a candidate for president and
then that military support which had
increased during the Trump
administration was suddenly put on hold
for inexplicable reasons Ukraine got the
message
it wasn't very inexplicable to Ukraine
and what's more Russia got the message
it wasn't very inexplicable to Russia
that had pushed out the whole propaganda
theory that it was Ukraine that had
interfered in our election and not
Russia and so that consensus among the
Congress and the administration among
the right and the left and the center
that is ambassador Taylor explained this
is not only vital to Ukraine's security
and the post-world War two order that
has kept the peace in Europe for 70
years but it's vital to us and our
security as well that all broke down
that all broke down over an effort led
by the President and is agent Rudy
Giuliani
and his agents paar nos and frou Minh to
overturn all that overturn a
decades-long commitment to standing up
to Russian aggression we have so
tremendously benefited no country has
benefited more from the international
rules of the road the international
order than the United States gave us the
peace and stability to prosper like no
other nation has before and we're
throwing it away we're throwing it away
we're undermining the rule of law were
undermining the principle you don't
invade your neighbor
we're undermining the key to our own
success and for what for help with a
political campaign to quote Bill Taylor
that's crazy
that's crazy
if our allies can't trust us to stand
behind them at a time of need we will
soon not have a single ally left look I
I know it's painful to see some of our
allies and how they talk about this
president because when they talk about
this president they're also talking
about the United States and it's painful
to see our allies distance themself from
the United States and it's more than
painful it's dangerous it's dangerous to
us I think it was Churchill once said
there's nothing worse than allies except
having no allies but if we're going to
condition our support for our allies on
their willingness to be dragged kicking
and screaming into our politics we're
going to condition the strength of our
alliance on whether they'll help us
cheat in an election we're not gonna
have a single Ally left and not a single
one of us in this chamber is ever going
to be able to say one of our
counterparts to respect the rule of law
without it being thrown in our face
promoting the rule of law and fighting
corruption is central to our foreign
policy it distinguishes u.s. global
leadership from the transactional
approach favored by authoritarian
adversaries the inherently corrupt
nature of the president's demand that
Ukraine investigate his political
opponent undermined the credibility of
efforts to promote the rule of law and
combat corruption in Ukraine and around
the world indeed the president engaging
in the very conduct at home that our
policy fights abroad sabotages
long-standing bipartisan pillars of
American diplomacy this was a problem
not least because the pervasive
corruption with Ukraine leaves its
politics and economy susceptible to
Russian influence and subterfuge
ambassador Jovanovic emphasized that US
policy in Ukraine has long recognized
that the struggle against corruption and
defending against Russia are in fact two
sides of the very same coin
corruption makes Ukraine's leaders ever
vulnerable to Russia and the Ukrainian
people understand that that's why they
launched the revolution of dignity in
2014
demanding to be a part of Europe
demanding the transformation of the
system demanding to live under the rule
of law
Ukrainians one of the law to apply
equally to all people whether the
individual in question is the president
or any other citizen it was a question
of fairness of dignity here again there
is a coincidence of interests corrupt
leaders are inherently less trustworthy
while an honest and accountable
Ukrainian leadership makes a u.s.
Ukrainian partnership more reliable and
more valuable to the United States a
level playing field in this
strategically located country ordering
for NATO allies creates an environment
in which US business can more easily
trade invest and profit corruption is
also a security issue because corrupt
officials are
to Moscow during that conversation that
we related in the past when ambassador
Volker urged his Ukrainian counterpart
Andrei Yair Mach not to investigate the
past president of Ukraine and Yarmouk
threw it back in his face you remember
the conversation no you mean like the
investigation you want us to do of the
Clintons and the Biden's they taught us
something in that conversation they
taught us that we'd forgotten for that
moment our own values you know just
listening to the ambassador right now I
was thinking how interesting it is the
Ukrainians chose to describe their
revolution as a revolution of dignity
and maybe that's what we need here a
revolution of dignity at home
a revolution of a civility here at home
maybe we can learn a lot a lot more from
our Ukrainian ally in short it is
America's national security interest to
help Ukraine transform into a country
where the rule of law governors and
corruption is held in check as we heard
yesterday anti-corruption policy was a
central part of the talking points
provided to President Trump before his
phone calls with President Solinsky on
April 21st and July 25th president Trump
of course didn't mention corruption but
importantly those same foreign policy
goals were made to intact following the
call as Tim Morrison testified
anti-corruption reforms institutional
reforms remain a top US priority to help
Ukraine fight corruption President
Solinsky was swept into office on an
anti-corruption platform immediately he
kept his promise and introduced numerous
bills in Ukraine's Parliament in a sign
that he intended to hold himself
accountable
zalanski even introduced a draft law
on presidential impeachment he also
introduced a bill to restore top
punishment of top officials found guilty
of illicit enrichment president Trump's
self-serving scheme threatened to
undermine zelinsky's anti-corruption
work Solinsky successful anti-corruption
reforms would have advanced us security
instead president Trump's demands
undermined that effort to bring about
reform to Ukraine here's George Kent a
rule of law and corruption expert at the
State Department US efforts to counter
corruption in Ukraine focus on building
institutional capacity so that the
Ukrainian government has the ability to
go after corruption and effectively
investigate prosecute and judge alleged
criminal activities using appropriate
institutional mechanisms that is to
create and follow the rule of law that
means that if there are criminal nexuses
for activity in the United States US law
enforcement should pursue the case if we
think there has been a criminal act
overseas that violates US law we have
the institutional mechanisms to address
that it could be through the Justice
Department and FBI agents assigned
overseas or through treating mechanisms
such as the mutual legal assistance
treaty as a general principle I do not
believe the United States should ask
other countries to engage in selective
politically associated investigations or
prosecutions against opponents of those
in power because such selective actions
undermine the rule of law regardless of
the country and so it's clear what
President Trump did when abusing his
office and demanding Ukraine open an
investigation into Joe Biden was not
fighting corruption it was not part of
established US anti-corruption policy
that corrupt pressure campaign for his
own personal political benefit in fact
subverted US anti-corruption efforts in
Ukraine and undercut our national
security
president Trump is not fighting to end
corruption in Ukraine as my colleague in
the house mr. hai
pointed out during one of our hearings
he was trying to aim corruption in
Ukraine at Vice President Biden and our
2020 election selectively politically
motivated prosecutions of political
opponents undercut governance in Ukraine
president Trump's demand that szalinski
help him do precisely what US diplomats
for decades advised Ukrainian officials
not to do completely undercut the
credibility of efforts to promote the
rule of law there the demand also
undercut the United States moral
standing and authority in the eyes of a
global audience here once again is
George Kent Candice is pressuring
Ukraine to conduct what I believe you've
called political investigations a part
of u.s. foreign policy to promote the
rule of law in Ukraine and around the
world it is not is it in the national
interest of the United States in my
opinion it does not why not because our
policies particularly in promoting the
rule of law are designed to help
countries and in Eastern Europe and
Central Europe that is overcoming the
legacy of communism in the communist
system in particular the prosecutor
general office was used to suppress and
persecute citizens not promote the rule
of law so in helping these countries
reach their own aspirations to join the
Western community of nations and live
lives of dignity helping them have the
rule of law with strong institutions is
the purpose of our policy so in other
words it is a purpose of our foreign
policy to encourage foreign nations to
refrain from conducting political
investigations is that right correct and
in fact as a matter of policy not of
programming we oftentimes raise our
concerns usually in private with
countries that we feel are engaged in
selective political prosecution and
persecution of their opponents the
Jovanovic aptly summarized the global
consequences and harm to US national
security results
from president Trump's demand that
Ukraine investigate his political
opponent such conduct undermines the
u.s. exposes our friends and widens the
playing field for autocrats like
President Putin our leadership depends
on the power of our example and the
consistency of our purpose both have now
been opened to question the issues I
just covered are not a matter a matter
of policy disagreement over foreign
policy and national security article 1
asserts that the president was engaged
in no such policy at all but it's dead
sold out our policies and our national
interests for his own personal gain and
to help him corrupt the next election
that is the core conduct of an
impeachable offense the president's
abuse of power also affected our
election integrity the framers of our
Constitution were particularly fearful
that a president might misuse or abuse
the power of his office to undermine the
free and fair elections at the heart of
our democracy sadly that moment has
arrived
president Trump's repeated solicitation
of a Ukrainian investigation was a clear
effort to leverage foreign interference
to bolster his prospects in the 2020
election in other words to cheat in his
election in our democracy power flows
from the will of the people as manifest
in free and fair elections one-person
one-vote is fundamental in our democracy
president Trump's invitation of foreign
interference in the 2020 election for
the purposes of helping him win an
election undercut the Constitution's
commitment to popular sovereignty
Americans are now left to wonder if
their vote matters or if they're simply
pawns in a system being manipulated by
shadowy foreign forces working on behalf
of corrupt interests of a lawless
president over the long term this
weakens our democratic systems capacity
for self-governance by encouraging
bethey and non-participation cynicism
makes it easier for enemies to influence
our politics and undermine the national
good indeed this is precisely what
Vladimir Putin intended when he meddled
in the 2016 election for us to become
more cynical for us to lose faith in the
notion that the American system of
government is superior to the corrupt
autocratic model of government that he
is erected in Russia and sought to
export to places like Ukraine these are
not the free and fair elections
Americans expect or demand if foreign
powers are interfering how can we know
that our elections are free from foreign
interference whether by disinformation
or hacking or fake investigations we
must not become numb to foreign
interference in our elections our
elections are sacred if we do not act to
put an end to the solicitation of
foreign interference in our election by
the President of the United States the
effect will be corrosive to our
elections and our values future
presidents may believe that they too can
use the substantial power conferred on
them by the Constitution in order to
undermine our system of free and fair
elections that they too can cheat to
obtain power or keep it that way lies
disaster for the great American
experiment in self-governance as you
have seen there is powerful evidence
that President Trump will continue to
betray the national interest to a
foreign power and further undermine both
our security and democracy this creates
an urgent need to remove him from office
before the next election to explain the
nature of that continuing threat let me
describe Russians ongoing efforts to
harm our elections the president's
corrupt refusal to condemn or defend
against those attacks his statements
confirming that he welcomes foreign
interference in our elections so long as
this is meant to help him
and his conduct proving that he will
persist in seeking to corrupt elections
at the expense of our security and at
expense of those elections let's start
with Russia's ongoing attacks on our
democracy at the heart of the
president's Ukraine scheme is his
decision to subscribe to that dangerous
conspiracy theory that Ukraine not
Russia was responsible for interfering
in 2016
president Trump and his men pressured
Ukraine into investigating this bogus
piece of Russian propaganda and in doing
so they aided Putin's concert concerted
plot to undermine our security and
democracy special counsel Muller warned
that Putin's plot was ongoing is this in
your investigation that you think that
this was a single attempt by the
Russians to get involved in our election
or did you find evidence to suggest
they'll try to do this again oh it
wasn't a single attempt they're doing it
as we sit here and they expect to do it
during the next campaign not a single
attempt they're doing it as we sit here
and they expect to do it in the next
campaign that was special counsel
Muller's stark warning and we now know
that director Muller was right just the
other week we saw public reporting that
Russian hackers may be using phishing
emails to attack the Ukrainian gas
company bur yzma presumably in search of
dirt on Joe Biden those are the same
tactics deployed by the same adversary
Russia that special counsel warned about
in the last election it may be Russia
once again attempting to sway our
election for one candidate this time
through Ukraine
indeed President Trump to this very day
refuses to accept the unanimous
assessment of intelligence community and
law enforcement professionals that
Russia interfered in the 2016 campaign
and poses a threat to the 2020
presidential election instead he views
it from his own personal lens whether it
is an attack on the legitimacy of his
2016 electoral victory special counsel
Miller's testimony on July 24 2019 the
day before the president's call with
President Solinsky contradicted
president Trump's claim that his was
quote a clean campaign Muller found that
individuals associated with the 2016
campaign of the president welcomed
Russia's offers of assistance and
adjusted their political strategy so
that then candidate Donald Trump might
benefit from Russia's assistance when
they were subsequently asked by US law
enforcement about their activities
president Trump's advisors repeatedly
lied in Helsinki in July of 2018 however
president Trump refused to acknowledge
the Russian threat to our elections when
Rapporteur explicitly asked whether he
believed Putin or the u.s. intelligence
agencies on the issue of foreign
interference in the 2016 election
President Trump said quote I don't see
any reason why it would be Russia and
talked about the DNC server so let me
just say that we have two thoughts you
have groups that are wondering why the
FBI never took the server
why haven't they taken the server why
was the FBI told to leave the office of
the Democratic National Committee I've
been wondering that up and asking that
for months and months and I've been
tweeting it out and calling it out on
social media where is the server I want
to know where is the server and what is
the server saying with that being said
all I can do is ask the question my
people came to me dan coates came to me
some others they said they think it's
Russia I have President Putin he just
said it's not Russia I will say this I
don't see any reason why it would be but
I really do want to see the server but I
have I have confidence in both parties I
really believe that this will probably
go on for a while but I don't think it
can go on without finding out what
happened to the server what happened to
the servers of the Pakistani gentleman
that worked on the DNC where are the
servers they're missing where are they
what happened to Hillary Clinton's
emails 33,000 emails gone just gone I
think in Russia they wouldn't begun so
easily I think it's a disgrace that we
can't get Hillary Clinton's 33,000
emails I agree I'm sure you remember
this it was I think unforgettable for
every American but I'm sure it was
equally unforgettable for Vladimir Putin
I mean there he is the President of
Russia standing next to the President of
the United States and hearing his own
Kremlin propaganda talking points coming
from the President of the United States
now if that's not a propaganda coup I
don't know what is it's the most
extraordinary thing it's the most
extraordinary thing the President of the
United States standing next to the
President of Russia our adversary saying
he doesn't believe his own intelligence
agencies he doesn't believe them he's
promoting this kooky crazy server theory
cooked up by the Kremlin right next to
the guy that cooked it up it's a
breathtaking success of Russian
intelligence I don't know if there's
ever been a greater success of Russian
intelligence whatever profile Russia did
of our president boy did they have him
spot-on flattery and propaganda
flattery and propaganda is all Russia
needed and as to Ukraine well they
needed to deliver a political
investigation to get help from the
United States I mean this is just the
most incredible propaganda coup because
as I said yesterday it's not just that
the president states standing next to
Vladimir Putin is is reading Kremlin
talking points he won't read his own
national security staff talking points
but he will read the Kremlin once but
it's not just that he adopts the Kremlin
talking points that would be bad enough
it's not bad enough it's not damaging
enough it's not dangerous enough to our
national security that he's undermining
our own intelligence agencies it's not
bad enough that that he undermines those
very agencies that he needs later that
we need later to have credibility
we've just had a vigorous debate over
these the strikes against general
Soleimani and the president has made his
argument about what the intelligence
says and supports how do you how do you
make those arguments when you say the US
intelligence community can't be believed
now we've had a vigorous debate about
what that intelligence has to say that's
not the issue here the issue here is you
undermine the credibility of your own
intelligence agencies you weak in the
country for when you need to rely on
them for when you need to persuade your
friends and your allies you can trust us
when we tell you this is what the
intelligence shows how do you make that
argument as the president itíd States
when you've just told the world you
trust the Russians more than your own
people you trust Rudy Giuliani more than
Christopher Rhea how do you make that
case and if you can't make that case
what does that mean to our security but
that's
not the end of it it's not just a
propaganda coup it's not just the
undermining of our agencies it's also
that the buy-in to that propaganda meant
that Ukraine wasn't going to get money
to fight the Russians I mean that's one
hell of a Russian intelligence coup they
got the president nine states to provide
cover for their own interference with
our election they got the president
United States to discredit his own
intelligence agencies they got the
president United States to drive a wedge
between the United States and Ukraine
they got the President of the United
States to withhold aid from right from
Ukraine in a war with Russia in a war
that is claiming Ukrainian lives every
week has there ever been such a coup I
would submit to you in the entire length
of the Cold War the Soviet Union had no
such success no such success and why
because a former mayor of New York
persuaded a president United States to
sacrifice all of that for a cheap shot
at his political opponent for a smear
against his political opponent was it
worth it I hope it was worth it I hope
it was worth it for the president
because it certainly would wasn't worth
it for the United States
now you could see president Trump did
not blame Vladimir Putin and the Russian
intelligence agencies who interfere in
our election for the questions
surrounding his victory he did not blame
the people who worked for his campaign
and were subsequently convicted of lying
to our law enforcement agencies no he
blamed the investigators special counsel
Muller the man charged with getting to
the bottom of Russia's interference in
2016 and he chose to believe Vladimir
Putin a former Russian intelligence
officer rather than his own intelligence
agencies we can see a pattern here
president Trump's illicit interference
from Russia as a candidate in 2016 and
then his campaign welcomed Russian
interference in the election in Helsinki
President Trump chose to believe Putin
over his own agencies I don't see any
reason why it would be referring to
Russia instead of denouncing Russia's
interference he denounced those
investigating Russia's interference and
he raised that now-familiar DNC
CrowdStrike
server thing I really do want to see the
server I don't think we can go on
without finding out what happened to the
server that's the exact same server at
present Trump demanded Ukraine
investigate during his July 25th call
and szalinski when the president talked
about the DNC server in Helsinki with
Vladimir Putin standing by his side he
was referencing the same discredited
conspiracy theory about Ukraine
interference in 2016 that Putin
repeatedly promoted let's look at this
Washington Post article from July 2018
in the end Trump's performance alongside
Putin the finished capital seemed like a
tour through his most controversial
conspiracy theories tweets and
off-the-cuff musings on Russia except he
did it all while
abroad standing just feet from Putin the
leader of one of America's greatest
geopolitical foes
spectacle and Helsinki also underscored
Trump's eagerness to disregard his own
advisers his willingness to flout the
conclusions of his own intelligence
community that Russia interfered in the
2016 elections and his apparent fear
that pressing Putin on the subject might
cast doubt on his electoral victory
White House officials told The
Washington Post that President Trump's
remarks in Helsinki were quote very much
countered to the plan that's another
understatement of the century if that
sounds familiar
it's because the witness who testified
before the house as part of the
impeachment inquiry they all said the
same thing about the July 25th phone
call president ignored vital national
security issues he was supposed to raise
and instead raised disproven
conspiracies about 2016 and the DNC
server the very same Russian propaganda
he publicly endorsed in Helsinki do you
think it's going to stop now do you
think if we do nothing it's going to
stop now all of the evidence is to the
country you know it's not going to stop
president just told one of the members
of this body he still wants Biden
investigated it's not going to stop
unless the Congress does something about
it
president Trump's betrayal began in 2016
when he first solicited Russian
interference in our election Russia if
you're listening I hope you're able to
find the 30,000 emails that are missing
that betrayal continued in Helsinki in
2018 when as we saw he rejected the
intelligence community's assessment
about Russian
interference in that same election when
he criticized US officials investigating
the Russia interference and instead
promoted Putin's conspiracy theory about
Ukraine The Betrayal continued in 2019
when he carried out a scheme to cheat in
the 2020 election by demanding that the
leader of Ukraine a u.s. partner under
military attack by Russia announced an
investigation into the same baseless
conspiracy theory about a DNC server and
the bogus allegations about Vice
President Biden and the abuse of power
continues he is still trying to cheat in
the next election even after the scheme
came to light even after became the
subject of an impeachment inquiry it
continued and the false statements about
it continued President Trump repeatedly
asserted that he had a prerogative to
urge for nations to investigate u.s.
citizens who dare to challenge him
politically you know I mean just for a
minute we should try to step into the
shoes of someone else my father used to
say you don't understand a person till
you step in their shoes I always thought
he he invented that wisdom is self until
I watched to kill a mockingbird and
found out that Atticus Finch said it
first but let's just try to step into
someone else's shoes for a moment let's
imagine it wasn't Joe Biden let's
imagine it was any one of us let's
imagine the most powerful person in the
world was asking a foreign nation to
conduct a sham investigation into one of
us what would we think about it then
would we think that's good US policy
would we think he has every right to do
it would we think that's a perfect call
let's step for a minute into ambassador
Jovanovic his shoes and we're the
subject of a vicious smear campaign that
no one in the department that we work
for
to the Secretary of State thinks has a
shred of credibility let's step into her
shoes for a minute spent our whole life
devoted to public service served in
dangerous places around the world and
we're hounded out of our post and one
day someone releases a transcript of a
call between the President of the United
States and a foreign leader and the
president says there's got to be some
things happening to you or to you or to
you or to you or to you how would you
feel about the President of the United
States would you think he was abusing
the power of his office and if you would
it shouldn't matter that it wasn't you
it shouldn't matter there was Murray
Ivanovich it shouldn't matter that was
Joe Biden because I'll tell you
something the next time it just may be
you it just may be you do you think for
a moment that any of you no matter what
your relationship with this president no
matter how close you are to this
president do you think for a moment that
even felt it was in his interest he
wouldn't ask you to be investigated do
you think for a moment that he wouldn't
and if somewhere deep down below you
realize that he would cannot leave a man
like that in office when he has violated
the Constitution shouldn't matter it was
Joe Biden could have been any of us it
made the end of us shouldn't matter that
was Murray Ivanovich it'll be some other
diplomat tomorrow for some other
pernicious reason goes to what mr.
Jeffries said it goes to character you
don't realize how important character is
in the highest office in the land until
you don't have it till you have a
president willing to use his power to
coerce an ally to help him cheat to
investigate one of our fellow citizens
one of our fellow citizens yes he's
running for president he's still a US
citizen he's still a US citizen and he
deserves better than that
now of course it wasn't just Ukraine it
wasn't just Russia
there's the invitation to China to
investigate the Biden's it's not going
to stop September 19th Rudy Giuliani was
interviewed on Chris Cuomo and CNN
you've probably all seen the clip when
asked specifically if he had urged
Ukraine to look into Vice President
Biden mr. Giuliani replied immediately
of course I did of course I did
shouldn't matter that it was Jill Biden
wasn't hunter Biden there it was Joe
Biden wasn't a hunter Biden on that call
that was Joe Biden but it shouldn't
matter what it's hunter Biden or Joe
Biden talking about American citizens
shouldn't matter to any of us
which American citizens and he hasn't
stopped urging Ukraine to conduct these
investigations mr. Giuliani hasn't
Donald Trump hasn't to the contrary and
consistent with everything we know about
the president he has done nothing but
double down during his first week the
first week of December mr. Giuliani
traveled to Ukraine and Hungary to
interview the corrupt former Ukrainian
prosecutors who had been pushing these
false narratives about Vice President
Biden and this kooky conspiracy about
2016 mr. Giuliani met with current
members of the Ukraine Parliament who
have advocated for that same fraudulent
investigation June of last year
President Trump told ABC News that he
would take political dirt from a foreign
country if he was offered it again if he
has learned anything from the tumult of
the last three years it is he can get
away with anything do it again
can't be indicted can't be impeached
can't if you believe our Attorney
General even be investigated our
founders worried about a situation just
like this
James Madison put it simply president
quote might betray his trust to foreign
powers in his farewell address George
Washington warned Americans to be
constantly awake since history and
experience prove that foreign influence
is one of the most baneful foes of
republican government John Adams in a
letter to Thomas Jefferson wrote you are
apprehensive of foreign interference
intrigue influence so am i but as often
as elections happen the danger of
foreign influence recurse or to quote
the president's chief of staff get over
it there's gonna be politics and foreign
policy well I don't think that was John
Adams point and I don't think that was
James Madison's point and I don't think
that was George Washington's point if it
was they would have said get over it
but they recognized as I know we
recognized what a profound danger that
would be for that to become the new
normal another election is upon us
ten months voters will undertake their
most important duty as citizens by going
to the polls and voting for their leader
and so we must ask what role were formed
powers play in trying to influence the
outcome and if they take the president's
side who will protect our franchise if
the president will not as charged in the
first article of impeachment President
Trump has demonstrated that he will main
a threat to Nash
security and the Constitution if allowed
to remain in office and has acted in a
manner grossly incompatible with
self-governance and the rule of law
based on the abuse of power for which he
was impeached and his ongoing efforts to
solicit foreign interference both
directly and through mr. Giuliani there
can be little doubt that President Trump
will continue to invite foreign
interference in our elections again and
again that poses an imminent threat to
the integrity of our democracy our
founders understood that a president
like Donald Trump might one day grasp
the reins of power an unremorseful
overreaching executive faithful to
himself only and willing to sacrifice
our democracy and national security for
his own personal advantage his pattern
of conduct repeatedly soliciting foreign
interference in our elections for his
own benefit confirms that he will stop
at nothing to retain his power he
willfully chose to place his own
personal interests above the country's
and the integrity of our elections there
is every reason to believe that will
continue via stonewalled Congress and
ordered executive branch agencies
organizations that work for the American
people not for the President to join in
his obstruction he deployed mr. Giuliani
to Ukraine to continue advancing a
scheme that serves no other purpose than
advancing his 2020 reelection prospects
he attacked witnesses public servants
Patriots who stayed true to their oath
and leveled with the American people
about the grave national injury that
resulted from the president's misconduct
and he continued to urge foreign nations
to investigate American citizens that he
views as a threat
the threat that he will continue to
abuse his power and cause grave harm to
the nation over the course of the next
year until a new president is sworn in
or until he would be reelected is not
hypothetical merely exposing the
president's scheme has not stopped him
from continuing this destructive pattern
of behavior that has brought us to this
somber moment he is Hui his that will
not change and nor will the danger
associated with him every piece of
evidence supports that terrible
conclusion that the President of the
United States will abuse his power again
that he will continue to solicit foreign
interference to help corruptly secure
his reelection he has shown neither
remorse nor acknowledgement of
wrongdoing if you can believe that July
25th was a perfect call that asking for
investigations of your political
opponents and using the power of your
office to make it so is perfectly fine
then there is nothing that would stop
you from doing it again
president Trump has abused the power of
his office and must be removed from that
office McConnell I yield back
the majority leader is recognized as
chief justice I suggest a 15-minute
recess without objection so ordered